welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and as the mysteries of moon night
continue to mount with the mayhem of
mark's mind the most mondo mystery is
what made mark march to the
mountainsides of germany anyway huh i
don't know about you but i feel like
steven grant is not asking enough
questions as to what exactly his other
self was doing to cause him to wake up
in the middle of the bavarian alps with
a sore job because if i woke up in the
middle of europe with a sore jaw and no
memories of what i did with my mouth i
would be quite concerned what if i told
you that haro and his ragtag team of
tattooed terrorists powered by lentil
soup were shooting the [ __ ] in the
bavarian alps for a secret magic nazi
reason no i'm not talking about indiana
jones i'm talking about red and racist
bones red skull because i believe hydra
will be very much involved within the
plot of moon knight and have already
shown themselves in episode one and i
think that this secret could possibly
help answer how arthur was able to
summon scooby-doo from another dimension
so let's go ahead and speculate better
babies because we're a speculation
nation after all and by the way speaking
of moon knight make sure to pick up the
latest obsession shirt these shirts are
not going to last forever they're
moonite inspired and this design is
literally my favorite design that we
have so far so head to
newrockstarsmerch.com to pick it up
because it's freaking tight episode one
a moon knight finds poor gift shop grant
with a gun on the run with some unsavory
types in the mountains of germany but
this isn't the first time that the mcu
has gone to the bavarian alps in germany
oh no in fact these very alps were the
home of the red skull himself the castle
the crank you know that place where
hydra's deepest roots in the dark world
of the occult were revealed by red skull
himself the tesseract was able to hold
the power to rewrite the very laws of
physics and unlock doors across the
universe as in the mcu it would be
within johann schmidt's castle in the
mountains of germany where he would make
the foolish decision to try his own
version of erskine's super soldier
formula on himself causing his
physiology to change completely and
become the red skull but as of this
point in this main mcu live action
universe we only know the name of red
skull's castle as castle kaufman with
kaufman being the last name of the nazi
officer ernst kaufman who schmidt killed
and stole his house keys from i think
that this castle kaufman ends up having
its name changed by the red skull to the
castle decrek to represent hydra's dark
arcane goal to bring their revered evil
squidward into the mortal plane through
the gateway opening powers of the
tesseract and red skull of course first
comes across the tesseract while on a
nazi vacation to townsburg norway where
the loyal worshipers of odin agreed to
hide the tesseract in their small
village on earth after he himself saved
them from the frost giants in the year
965 like a good god that actually
listens to his people and is currently
where king valkyrie's new asgard stands
if this magic loving scientist red skull
spent so much of hydra's time and
hitler's resources chasing magical
objects like the tesseract across the
earth and with phase four of the mcu
beginning to show us more and more
artifacts of dark influence when woos
hen rings dane whitman's ebony blade or
the godbutcher's necrosword agatha
harkness starkhold and now seemingly
arthur harrow's life-draining jackal
summoning kane there is a good chance
that redskull had a huge stash of a
bunch of old magical items with one of
those items being the very mcgovern of
the moonlight series the golden scarab
which steve unwillingly has in his
possession when he wakes up we could be
looking at a scenario where mark spector
as moon knight stopped arthur harrow and
his cult from looting the abandoned
former home of the red skull to find his
golden scarab that red skull might have
found a long long time ago but never got
around to finding the use for now it's
not good to get something intended for
someone else whether it's a restaurant
order or a medical diagnosis you want to
get the thing that was intended for you
because no doubt and thanks to helix you
can get the mattress specifically made
for you helix fleet makes premium
mattresses and bedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped right to your
door helix has a sleep quiz that matches
your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you i took the quiz and i got matched
with the helix plus mattress because i
wanted a mattress for a bigger man like
myself and it gives me a ton of support
and i've never slept as good in my life
like that is for real i'm not just
saying this i love my helix mattress i'm
looking at it right now i love you
i got it not too long ago and i
absolutely love it like i i've never
like before i used to wake up like with
my body sore for some reason but with my
helix mattress i've never slept better
thank you helix like legit
thank you
but i really appreciate it and helix
delivers your mattress right to your
door for free and it comes rolled up in
a surprisingly small box and is super
easy to set up yourself and helix has a
100 night sleep trial so that you can
get more than three months to make sure
that you love it and if you don't
they'll pick it up for you and you'll
get a full refund i love my helix and i
think you would too and if you're
looking for a new bed check out helix
you can click the link below or go to
helixsleep.com rockstars to get up to
200 off your helix mattress that's helix
sleep.com rockstars but red skull was of
course not alone in his efforts to be a
douchebag because none of red skulls mcu
achievements could have been possible
without schmidt's right hand swiss
arnhem zola who as we remember from
captain america winter soldier crafted
the project insight formula that was
designed to scan the digital brains of
everyone on the planet in an effort to
predict future threats to the hydra
cult's vision for the future with one of
those threats even suspiciously being
the magical sorcerer supreme himself
doctor strange zola's algorithm is a
program for choosing insights targets
what targets bruce banner steven strange
anyone who's a threat why would a cult
be after a magic man hmm it's because
they're a cult but wait a minute doesn't
that sound familiar to you a cult
wanting to scan people to try to create
their version of heaven on earth hmm
sounds a lot like arthur harrow and his
cane of judgment to me because doesn't
he sound like nick fury concho punishes
those who have already walked an evil
path his retribution comes too
late by the time his fist of vengeance
arrives people have already suffered
these new long-range precision guns can
eliminate a thousand hostiles a minute
the satellites can read a terrorist dna
before he steps outside the spider hole
gonna neutralize a lot of threats before
they even happen i believe his kane is
infused with both blue cosmic tesseract
energy and red chaos magic to make the
purple glow of his cane and it's through
that very chaos magic gift from homage
that arthur harrow is able to interface
with the neurons of people's brains to
scan them directly to try to predict
their future because you gotta remember
that all of our neurons connect to our
brain and so when he touches people's
hands he's scanning their brains
something that we learn is actually
established within mcu canon that chaos
magic can do in avengers age of ultron
her thing is neuroelectric interfacing
and why wanda was able to control all of
the minds of westview in a very similar
way to how arthur harrow seems to be
controlling the minds of all of his
weird-ass followers who just watch whale
footage with blank faces and laugh in
unison which is why arthur harrow is
able to detect the red chaos magic in
mark when he scans his brain this chaos
and also potentially why he was able to
use the same cane to open a tesseract
tesseract-like wormhole to summon a
creature from another dimension like the
red skull did in what if so this all
being said with zola being so closely
tied to the red skull's obsession with
collecting magical items of the past and
converting them into weapons for the
glory of hydra there is a chance that
zola's algorithm actually came from that
very cane that harrow now holds because
baby harrow got that cane thread skull
stash but either way i highly advise
that you all keep an eye out for hydra
during this incredible season of moon
night because hydra is always lurking in
the shadows y'all possibly even under
the new direction of a contessa
valentina de fontaine countess of the
castle that craved after the death of
one castle baron johann schmidt anyways
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me at
mastertainment on twitter and follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media hit up new rockstarsmerch.com
because this shirt is one of the cooler
shirts that i own thanks again for
watching this video and i will see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you